so people used to make fun of and we may
have even done it ourselves dr phil's
show is some kind of celebrity freak
show arena but in real life in 2020
two
you may find more interesting and more
honest guests on dr phil's show than
you're going to find an nbc news case in
point
dr phil recently interviewed lyla rose
the pro-life activist she's not getting
on morning joe so she came on a guest
tried to shout her down and here's how
she reacted
you have no empathy uh abortion is
devastating to women's mental health no
one talks about that the year after a
woman has an abortion it's really like
the year after a woman to have the child
what kind of trauma is the trauma is
dropping on everybody the trauma is from
the rape the child's an innocent party
there the child we don't we're not
jenna's not there we should not take out
generational sin on a child to say
there's generational sin and that dad
was an abuser
should be killed
about rights and he just said we've been
taken a right has been taken away from
us and what is i want to address that
because our fundamental human right that
we all share in this room is life it's
the first human right laws are meant to
protect the weak in a society who's the
weakest who's the weakest in the society
a child but whether you live 10 minutes
or 10 years or 100 years your human life
and you have the right to not be killed
it's kind of an amazing exchange the
nose ring girl is clearly damaged she's
mad deeply mad about something and lila
rose this isn't easy we can tell you
stays totally calm
during the whole thing she's president
of live action she joins us tonight rose
thank you uh for coming on and for
showing how
you you really do win an argument not by
drowning the other person out with rage
or shouting him down but by calmly
saying what you really think i think
i think you win people when you do that
well thanks tucker i mean it's i'm
fighting and we're fighting for
something really beautiful that's human
lives and so it's and and what's there
to be
um you know worked up over
it's the evil of abortion but at the end
of the day the truth sets people free so
when we are equipped with the truth to
share that and if i go on a show like dr
phil and sharing facts that are you know
about scientific development of human
life in the womb facts about the evil of
abortion um the facts speak for
themselves so it's it's a it's a
powerful message that i'm privileged to
get to share
you never dismiss i noticed the
suffering
of the young woman or any woman who's
pregnant doesn't want to be there's
obviously real suffering there she feels
helpless and terrified but you also
point out that abortion killing this
child
hurts the woman too and maybe that's why
there's so much rage around this issue
i mean i think you're spot on we're
actually about to launch can't stay
silent which is a white paper but also a
series of many videos testimonies of
women who've had abortions and have the
courage afterwards to speak out about
how devastating abortion was for them
the metadata proves that there are
serious mental health risks to women who
have abortions afterwards in the year
after having an abortion 150
percent more likely to commit suicide so
that message is part of the message to
say listen don't do it choose life there
are people that want to help you and
life is worth fighting for and if you
cared about women as they say they do at
planned parenthood you would care about
that but they don't care about women
exactly they care about more abortions
of course lila rose i appreciate your
coming on and your calmness thank you
thanks tucker
subscribe to the fox news youtube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from tucker carlson
tonight